the basement scene in Inglorious
Bastards deep in the movie Yes I mean
deep in the [__] movie and there's no
Aldo there's no shashana there's nobody
you know a bunch of [__] you
just met
it's like there's there's the scene
above ground and the scene below ground
and the scene above ground is what's
going on and the dialogue and them
sitting around this table and talking
underneath it it's like the suspense is
a rubber band and I'm just stretching it
and stretching it and stretching and see
how far it can stretch laser
I just started writing it and it kept
holding then I'd go over it again and
like I like it I I think it holds you
know and dare I say I think it makes it
more suspenseful I think the longer I
can stretch this rubber band out and
actually feel that there's more rubber
there to give the more suspenseful it it
will be that scene is more suspenseful
at 22 minutes and would be at eight so
you want to just stretch it until the
rubber band breaks